In this video, I used a new Opus 4.8 and
made it my senior SEO consultant. It did
a full SEO audit, as we can see in the
report here. It gave me actionable
insights based upon real data data of my
website, did a competitor analysis, and
then gave me a checklist of what to do
next to improve my overall SEO and rank
higher and outrank my competitors.
If you want the full SOP, continue
watching today's video. So, as you can
see here, Opus 4.8 just dropped a couple
of hours ago, and we've already went
ahead and used it in our CloudSkills.
So, the specific skill in which I used
here was the ultimate SEO skill. Now, if
you want to use this skill, just comment
SEO and I'll send you over this skill.
But, we can see we just entered in this
skill, and then I told it to please do
this competitive research for my
software, which is WordRocket.ai. Do a
full competitive analysis. I just told
it to be wary of my tokens cuz I didn't
want to go over my tokens cuz Opus 4.8
will eat of your tokens. It went ahead
and did a full analysis, and it went
ahead and then gave me all that
information in a beautiful, I must say,
very very well-designed report.
So, again, we get the executive summary.
Um it talks about WordRocket, who we
compete with, our competitors, what's
our unique um value proposition. Then it
gave me some actionable things that I
need to improve upon to our homepage,
that we need to include and create more
comparison pages of WordRocket with our
other competitors. And then it gave me
some information just about the category
and how to angle ourselves as um an
expert within this space. So, we see we
get a full competitor analysis from
Quala Writer, SEO Writing.ai, Journalist
AI, Surfer SEO, and so on. Then we get
keyword opportunity. So, these are core
money keywords. So, keyword that is
actually going to bring us in targeted
traffic and actually going to help us to
grow our software and get new uh users.
So, we get the SEO content writer. This
is four variants of this keyword,
high-value commercial cluster, AI
content generator, and we see how those
um keywords are either rising in
popularity or they're decreasing in
popularity as we can see from these
lower keywords as well. So, a lot of
really rich data here that we get back
that we can use to, you know, find
what's really going to move the needle
for our website. So, the biggest biggest
gap here we see, technical SEO audit.
So, we can go through this and make any
changes. Content gap analysis, this is
kind of what we talked about. So, more
comparison, best X tools use case, GEO
and answer engine pillar. So, we need to
write content in a more um fan out way
to get more traffic from search engines,
and then we get our action plan. So, it
gave us this full in-depth analysis,
which was really really good. I then
went ahead and told
Claude that I want you to use Word
Rocket, and I want you to then find the
biggest opportunity of keywords in which
you can write on, which was best AI SEO
tools, and then I want you to use Word
Rocket to write the full article. So, we
took the keyword best AI SEO tools, web
search mode is enabled, three images,
and I turned off internal linking and
publishing for now, but it also went
ahead and added in its own uh
information as to what would be useful
for this specific blog. So, it's now
asking me to generate the article from
Word Rocket. I've clicked allow, give it
a couple of minutes, and we'll start
generating the article in Word Rocket.
So, not only can you use this workflow
to do a competitive SEO analysis, you
could also use it to write your content
um using Claude, never having to log
into Word Rocket, and then you can just
copy over your content manually, or if
you have a if you have it connected on
Word Rocket, you can publish it
automatically over to your WordPress or
your Ghost or any webhook or API. So,
super super powerful and automated.
Okay, so after a couple of minutes the
article will be generated in WordRocket.
If you head over to WordRocket and
articles here, I should be able to see
an article. Here it is, best AI SEO
tools of 2026. So, here we have the full
article with the title,
key takeaways, best tools. As you can
see, beautiful beautiful images here.
Looks really really good. Table of
tables and then we get a list of best
SEO tools of 2026.
FAQ, conclusion, and we also get a nice
HTML element here that we can use
throughout our article.
Meta title, meta description. Beautiful
beautiful article there.
So, that is how you can use Opus 4.8 to
be your SEO consultant and to do your
SEO for you and give you actionable
insights. If you guys liked today's
video, give us a big thumbs up and I'll
see you in the next one. Take care.